[synthesizer music]
>>Adam: Hi, everyone.
My name is Adam Koch.
Welcome to the second week of Android Design
in Action.
For those of you who don't know me, I work
on the Developer Relations team on Android
here in New York.
I'm joined by Nick Butcher in London.
He is to my left over there.
How's it going, Nick?
>>Nick: Good.
Good to see you, Adam.
>>Adam: So, thanks for joining us.
For those of you who aren't familiar with
the show, the show is designed to follow on
from Reto and Ian Ni-Lewis's show that they
have on Friday called the App Clinic where
they look at a number of different apps.
And what we're trying to do here is re-imagine,
redesign some of the screens in those apps.
Nick, anything else to add?
>>Nick: No.
This is the second time we've done this show,
so we're still feeling our way around the
best way to do things.
So if you have any comments, feedback on what
you'd like to see, if there's something you'd
like to see more of, then let us know.
But yeah, the real goal is to really use these
make overs to demonstrate how you can use
Android design in your every day apps.
>>Adam: Yeah.
And I want to give a special shout out to
Jeff Posnick, who's actually running all the
fancy equipment for us today.
You should listen in to his show as well on
the YouTube API which is generally weekly
as well.
One thing I did wanna quickly mention is that
some people asked some questions about how
we set up the show and what kind of equipment
we're using here.
And I just wanted to say that we're using
this really fancy tablet here--it's called
the Motorola XOOM--to show us our screen shots.
And it's plugged into an HDMI and fed into
a central system here that loops in all the
different video feeds.
So with that, let's get started.
Today's focus is stopwatch and timers.
So, hopefully you watched the App Clinic last
week and saw some of the apps that they went
over.
Why don't we switch it over to demo?
[pause]
Alright.
>>Nick: Great, yeah.
So, actually set it last Friday.
Ian and Reto took a look at a number of stopwatch
and timer apps and gave their opinions on
what they liked, what they were looking for
in their applications and what they didn't
like.
So, the first application we're looking at
here is called Hybrid Stopwatch and Timer.
So this came out as one of Ian and Reto's
favorite applications.
They enjoyed the functionality and the design
and the big feature graphic on their Market
page.
So, what we've done here is we've taken a
look at it and said, "Yeah, it's got some
pretty good functionality, but there's a few
ways in which we'd like to see Android design
applied to it."
So, taking a quick look at the screen shot
here, you can see the stopwatch page, which
lets you start stopwatch using the big red
button in the middle as well as record a number
of laps and resets.
And it gives you that timer up at the top
and it shows you your latest lap time in the
orange bar just below.
If you want to go to the subsequent page,
on the right you can see that it also lists
out all the lap times you recorded during
your session.
So, we looked at this and we, the first thing
that strikes me really is it's quite what
we refer to as a skeuomorphic design.
So, it's really trying to imitate real life
in a digital surrounding.
While that can be great for bootstrapping
the user's mental model, it's getting them
to instantly see something familiar and recognize
it, you have to be aware that when you use
this kind of design, it's also gonna bring
across people's limitations of the physical
world.
It's gonna start, if you have a book application
that looks just like a book--a real book--you
can't really just copy the page, the text,
or do a Wikipedia search for a certain word.
So, those kind of features might not become
obvious, or might not sit very well with the
design, which is really skeuomorphic.
So, there's pluses and minuses to this school
of design.
It's also quite associated with the IOS world.
Another thing we notice is there's quite a
liberal use of gradients throughout the application.
So, every bar and so on has this textured
gradient feel, which is, doesn't quite sit
at home in the Android look and feel, the
Holo design philosophy really.
And from a technical point of view we've noticed
that it's not targeting the latest versions
of Android.
So, it's using the legacy menu button, as
you can see, emulated down at the bottom.
If you go to the next slide, Adam, you can
see if you pop open the menu, they're actually
using that as one of the primary means of
navigation.
So, this isn't really very advised.
Not everyone's gonna look under the menu button
for the navigation.
They might not even realize that there are
other features in the application, such as
the timer.
It has some advanced preferences in here.
So what we'd really like to see them do is
move towards the latest APIs, which should
be using an action bar to expose these kind
of functionality and navigation controls on-screen.
Also, if they target the latest APIs, they'd
benefit from the latest Holo themes and styles.
So, things like the updated scroll bar styles
and new text fonts and so on.
They would benefit from all these modern look
and feel.
How about that, Adam?
Do you have any thoughts about the look and
feel of this, the Hybrid Stopwatch and Timer
app?
>>Adam: Yeah, yes.
So, to me, like the actual stopwatch itself
looks quite nice.
As you say, it's trying to mimic real world
object.
But when they go and actually show the lap
times and then they have to reuse those gradients
to really make it sort of look the same as
the stopwatch, that's when it, the design
starts to fall apart if you ask me.
It just doesn't look quite as nice.
It doesn't really fit with the Android system
at that point.
So I mean, it's a choice every designer and
developer needs to make when they design their
app.
It's totally a valid choice if you think it
serves your users better that way, then that's
totally fine.
So, that's the design piece of it.
As far as the navigation or getting around
the application, as you said, they're using
the old-style menus.
And to me, that's not like a, visual design
aside, navigation in this app is very difficult.
It's one of the reasons why the menu button
has been deprecated now.
It's very difficult to find those additional
features in the application.
And I think the guys mentioned this in the
App Clinic on Friday, but not all devices
have soft, on-screen buttons on the bottom.
So, for example, the HTC One X device will
show that menu button as a horizontal button,
taking up the entire bottom portion of the
screen.
>>Nick: Yeah.
>>Adam: So, it instantly makes your application
look not up-to-date, not using the latest
Android API versions.
>>Nick: The button of shame, I think they
call it on the App Clinic, right?
>>Adam: [laughs] Is that what they call it?
Yes, the button of shame.
>>Nick: So, what did we do with it?
>>Adam: All right.
Oh, and I should mention that our favorite
pixel pusher Roman Nurik is off on vacation.
I guess we let him have one day off from work.
But he's here in spirit because this design
was actually something he worked on last week.
So here we go.
>>Nick: Ta-da.
>>Adam: Ta-da.
And reveal.
So, I guess I can talk through the navigation
elements first, and then maybe Nick, you can
add some comments.
So, what you see at the top, you've got the
action bar, which we love, the anchor of the
screen.
You've got the icon in the top left corner,
the branding.
And then, right next to that, you've got the
top level navigation.
So, in this case, it's a spinner with the
currently selected item, which is the stopwatch.
Right next to that you have an action item,
reset, and the action overflow.
And then what we've done here is underneath,
there's two tabs which are made to easily
navigate between the action timer itself and
the different lap times, sort of list view
collection of a particular object.
And then, obviously, you've got the nice Holo
theming throughout the whole application there.
It's worth noting that actions like stop and
lap, they could be in the action bar, but
because they're so important and so critical
to this application it warrants pointing them
out and having them in a more visible and
easily accessible place.
Nick, thoughts?
>>Nick: Yeah, so for me, this instantly jumps
out as just feeling right at home in the Android
look and feel.
I think the application of the Holo styling
married with a accent color, which we picked
out from the original application, the orangy,
browny color is from the original application.
We've used those to hint the default Holo
widgets set and create the clock face.
And I just think it instantly looks much,
much more Androidy to me.
So, like you said, I like use of the action
bar 'cause instantly it feels familiar to
me.
I instantly know how to switch modes between
timer and stopwatch just by looking at this.
Incidentally, 'cause this app has these two
different modes you can run it in, timer and
stopwatch, having that name right up there
in the title next to the icon is super useful.
So, if I am switching back to the application
from resets, for example, I have the name
echoed back to me right there.
So, straight away, I know which mode I'm in.
I think having, pulling out the lap times
into a separate tab makes it much more visible.
I don't have to discover them under the menu
and switch to them.
They're instantly there and just a swipe away
so you can use the horizontal swipe to get
to them.
So, it's really brought that functionality
out.
Looking at the stop and lap, I consider that
like this action bar almost.
So, for me, it feels like an extension of
the actions in the application.
But what's great about this is they've really
pulled out the key actions of start and stop
into much larger tap target.
It makes the most important things you do
in the app, like starting and stopping for
a stopwatch, super easy and like, front and
center.
The other thing I really like about this redesign
that Roman has done is the use of typography.
So, this is something we keep on going on
about, but using different weights and colors
of typography to give structure and emphasis
to the application.
So, I found in the old application, on the
left-hand side, all those leading zero digits
I find add noise.
So, I find it harder to read it and quickly
understand the time.
Whereas in the redesign, using a different
color or weight for the fonts, you can really
make the important information stand out.
[pause]
>> Adam:Yeah, definitely
>>Nick: So, for me, that's some of the major
benefits.
One thing to talk about is we've always not
included the advert in the redesign, which
obviously helps it feel a bit cleaner.
But thinking about that, I was thinking you
could easily just include the advert when
it's in the non-running mode.
So, for example, when you're actually using
the stopwatch and it's running, you'd be able
to clear that away and have a very clean interface
in the down time when you're between actually
running stopwatches, you could pop it in.
So if you go into the next page as well, we've
taken a quick look at the lap times as well.
OK.
So, Roman's done the same redesign, applied
the same treatment to the second tap here.
So, here we can see, rather than using all
these different gradients, we've gone for
a much flatter, Holo style again and really,
really cut down on all the chrome and just
let the content stand out.
So, one of my favorite aspects of this design
is the use of color.
So, you can see here, we've picked out using
green and reds to show the fastest and slowest
lap times.
So instantly, once you break away from the
constraints of having all these, all this
chrome, or the gradients surrounding the content,
it lets you do more interesting things with
content and lets it shine.
>>Adam: Yeah that's [ inaudible ].
>>Nick: Any more thoughts, Adam?
>>Adam: Yeah, so two other things I wanted
to quickly mention.
One, I really like the share action directly
in the action bar there, so you can quickly
share out your lap times and whatnot.
I believe before it was in, OK.
There was no way to actually share before,
I guess, using the regular menu but that's
a really nice addition.
And the other thing is, a lot of people ask
me about I guess second-level navigation or
how can I add a filter to my application to
a list?
So, for example, in a movie application, you
might have top movies and then you wanna filter
by genre, but you wanna have it all on the
same screen.
So, what was added here is a secondary spinner
or drop down underneath the action bar where
you can choose lap time or total time.
And I think this is a really nice way of adding,
easy way to change or filter the content on
that particular screen.
It's really clear that it falls underneath
the lap times on the right side.
It doesn't apply to everything.
And it's just a really easy way and visually
simple way to tell the user that there's a
way to change the visuals on that particular
screen.
The other option, which I've seen used which
is also a decent option, is to actually put
something in the action bar, which is tied
to the fragment that sits on that tab.
It could be like a little filter icon or something.
And clicking that would again, pull a little
drop down which you could quickly use to change
something on that particular screen.
>>Nick: OK.
>>Adam: What else?
>>Nick: I think also just having the laps
and the stopwatch on the same hierarchical
level of each other on separate tabs is great
'cause you can obviously have the stopwatch
still running and switch over to have a quick
look at the lap times you've done and switch
back to the still running stopwatch.
And it's much, much more apparent that these
are siblings in that kind of hierarchy when
they're on tabs, rather than the old design
when you were perhaps having to go in and
out of different screens and you couldn't
see those two elements on the screen at the
same time.
So I could see your way of, you could perhaps
decorate the stopwatch icon in redesign, like
make it glow somehow or have a different highlight
state to show that the stopwatch is still
running or stopped to indicate that at the
same time 'cause it's on-screen.
>>Adam: Yeah, that's an excellent point.
I guess one last thing I just wanna quickly
mention was--I think you mentioned this before--but
the use of typography and also the font sizes.
For example, this screen where you've got
the stopwatch and lap time.
It's very small, not much padding around it.
It's kind of difficult to see, whereas in
the redesign, you can very easily make out
lap time there.
And then, the same on this screen.
You've got list view on the left side on the
old design taking up just three rows, yet
it's hard to read the text.
There's not a lot of padding.
There's not a lot of, it's visually not easy
to break out.
>>Nick: It might be a case where you wanna
look at the data, if you have analytics in
your application, and see how many lap times
people often record and use that sizing information
to inform your decision.
I mean, here we're making an assumption that
five or six lap times at most are gonna be
shown, or else you might end up running out
of room.
>>Adam: That's true.
That's a good point.
>>Nick: Cool.
>>Adam: Excellent.
So, should we move along here?
>>Nick: Yeah.
So this next application is called Impetus
and it's an interval timer.
So, it's an application for people doing workouts
pretty much where you want to do repeated
intervals of workouts.
So, we're gonna take a look at one particular
screen in this application, which is the edit
screen, which lets you set up one of these
interval sessions.
So, taking a look here on the screen on the
left, you can see we're in an edit tab for
editing that particular set up.
And it lets you enter a period for, of prep
before your interval training session and
then a number of rounds of interval that you're
gonna go through, made up of work and rest
periods.
And then a cool down at the end, giving you
a total.
And what happens when you edit these values,
each of these rows per se, a tappable clicking
on which launches a pop-up you see on the
next screen, which gives you a spinner and
the option to go back to the screen and choose
another time to set or use the arrow buttons
to advance back or forth between the different
sections.
So, taking a look at this, Adam, do you wanna
give any initial thoughts on this photo screen?
>>Adam: So first of all, they are using action
bar and they have the design, tab designs
and whatnot there.
So, that's a great start.
I think the guys on Friday mentioned this
as well.
As far as this sort of, I guess, work flow
goes, going through and adding all these things,
to me it seems like a lot of work.
Like, a lot of tapping, a lot of changing.
It's not really, when I see all these fields
and I know I have to configure them all, to
me it's already in my head and mentally, it
makes it feel like a lot of work to me.
I do like how they added the arrows, so that's
an attempt to make it easy to quickly navigate
through the different things, but I'm not
sure if it like, really, it really solves
the problem of quickly getting through and
configuring all these things.
>>Nick: To expand on that feeling hard, for
me it's what you would refer to as a mode
problem because in the first sense, you launch
the app.
You come in and you see a particular timer
and then you have to hit the edit tab, which
is like going into edit mode.
So, it's like you're already in mode on top
of the standard timer.
And then, every time you hit edit, there's
a pop-up which comes up on top, which is like
a mode on top of the mode in my mind.
So, this is--.
>>Adam: Must go deeper.
>>Nick: When you're putting all these different
layers on top of each other, you're asking
the user to hold a lot of state in their mind,
which is what makes it feel hard to use or
hard to keep it all in your mind at once.
So that's one of the main problems which we've
really tried to address with it.
Some other minor stuff I wanted to call out
from the page as well is it had a good attempt
to theming the Holo look and feel.
So you can see they've used the orange accent
on the tap bar, for example, which picks out
the color schemes from their icon, which is
great.
But they haven't quite taken that further
throughout the application.
So you see when the pop-up comes up to show
the time.
They're using the standard Holo dark blue
accents.
So, 'cause you have these two different color
accents on-screen, for me that feels a bit
like a clash and that they haven't really
gone far enough with the customizations.
I'd like to see that kept consistent throughout
really.
>>Adam: Yeah, that's a good point.
And just on that, they are using the dialog
header from the Holo theme, but then everything
below that in the dialog just doesn't conform
to the standard Holo theme at all.
You've got this custom time picker, which
is lighter in color.
And then below that, you've got three buttons
which aren't the standard dialog buttons from
the Holo theme either.
>>Nick: Yeah.
If there's a dialog, I expect to see the button
bar style where you have just the outline
separating like the OK, cancel buttons or
whatever the buttons might be.
And another one--it might sound minor as well--but
just looking at the main screen on the left,
the alignment feels really off.
It feels like the total isn't aligned to the
things below it.
And then, within each of the rows, the text
is hard-lined to the left and not quite center
aligned vertically.
So for me, just looking at it, it just feels
unwieldy.
It doesn't feel very regular or very even
at all.
There's no extra weight given to total, even
though that is, you know, totaling up what's
going on.
And at first blush, it might not be obvious
that rounds refers to, the eight rounds refer
to work and rest periods, but not to the cool
down or prep.
They're separate to those things.
There's no grouping or anything there.
So, for me, there's quite a lot going on.
It's not particularly aligned to make it easy
to scan and understand what's going on.
>>Adam: Yeah, and we have a recommended standard
padding that you have in use around the different
text fields.
And you can see here it's just the text fields
are up against the sides of the screen on
both sides.
So, some padding there would have definitely
helped as well.
>>Nick: Right.
So onto the redesign.
>>Adam: It's, here we go.
[pause]
Is that synced over for you now?
>>Nick: Yeah.
I can see it now.
[laughs] Cool.
So, what we've gone for here with the redesign
is--.
>>Adam: Also, one quick thing.
Our very own Nick Butcher did this redesign.
So, good stuff there, Nick.
Go ahead.
>>Nick: In Roman Nurik's absence, there's
a poor substitute there.
I do with it what I can.
So what we've gone for here with this redesign
is more like a wizard-style.
So, the idea here is that you come in to this
summary screen showing you what's the summary
of the workout is and then you can swipe right,
go through each of the individual sections
that you can configure, each of which contains
a number picker letting you set it.
So, we've gone for like a scroll bar indicator
at the bottom as well to indicate that there
is this horizontal scrolling affordance, very
similar to the home screen, the default home
screen you might have in the launcher app
on Android.
And also, clicking on each of the items would
jump you to the right section.
So, the idea here is instead of having to
go in and out of each of the sections with
dialog popping up, being dismissed, a new
dialog popping up, being dismissed, you have
this one consistent wizard feel that lets
you configure the whole thing.
And then you're done.
And speaking of done, instead of having it
as a mode within the main UI, it's a tab within
the main UI.
We've launched this as its own separate activity
and used a pattern copied from contacts and
calendar applications, where we had this done
and discard bar at the top.
So instantly, this bar stays the same and
you know how to dismiss it and say, "Yes,
I'm done, " or "No, get rid of this."
Have any thoughts, Adam?
>>Adam: Yeah.
I really like the layout you've chosen here
with the big edit timer.
Sorry, the little thing's coming off.
And then you've also bolded and made the total
time really, really noticeable and easy to
read.
As far as the actual wizard goes, I think
that's a pretty unique take on it.
There's something that's traditionally pretty
mundane, like filling out a bunch of fields
like in a preference-style screen.
You've taken and really made it into something
more interesting.
So, just so I've got this right, the initial
screen is a summary and then you can either
start swiping left, swiping across to edit
each of them one by one, or if you want to
jump to a specific one, you just tap on it
and it'll slide across to the correct field.
Is that right?
>>Nick: Yeah.
Will you show us the next slide on the XOOM?
[pause]
>>Adam: Ah.
Bingo.
>>Nick: OK.
So here's an example.
You tap on the rounds link on the center,
for example.
It'll pan you across to the right page and
you'll get a standard Android number picker.
And so, you can progress, keep on swiping
across to go to the next one.
And as you can see at the bottom, there's
the scroll bar affordance at the bottom, similar
to the home screen letting the user know where
they are in the page, how far along they are,
and also just signifying that there is this
horizontal swipe affordance.
>>Adam: Yeah.
And I definitely like how it's its own screen
rather than being a tab on the main screen.
As you were talking about modes before, like
to me this is much clearer.
It's almost like when I'm viewing a contact
or editing a contact, viewing a timer or editing
a timer.
So I really like that.
And then I noticed that you've got this standard
system number picker here as well, which fits
in nicely with the Holo theme.
>>Nick: Yeah.
Speaking of Holo theme, we've really gone
for using just typography and standard controls
to give the application structure rather than
having these bounding boxes, which you used
to have around the controls.
So you can see we've used the different colors,
for example, like on total and edit.
It just give the, make those stand out as
important sections rather than putting dividing
lines in and so on and lining things up, really.
So, we've used the standard 48 DP rhythm here
to give the application this steady rhythm,
which makes it much easier to scan and read
and understand what's going on very quickly
and make certain things jump out, like the
total time.
We've also taken the orange accent color,
which the original application used in the
tab bar, and run with it and really use that
to theme everything.
So, from the standard number picker to the
page title and the total bar, for example.
[pause]
>>Adam: Excellent.
I really like it.
One question, so around the done and discard,
I think we had a slide on this last week as
well.
Why the twist to show both at the same time
rather than, say, push one into the overflow
menu?
>>Nick: So, I would say that really comes
down to the expected behavior here.
So, how is the user gonna use this?
If it's the kind of thing where they're gonna
come in and then once get rid of the, what
they've done, is quite likely, then I think
having discard as a primary option works very,
very well.
If it's something where they expect to back
out and not have it discard what they've done,
but have it just cancel the edit--so think
about editing a contact, for example--you
wanna have a big done button at the top, but
you're very unlikely to want to actually just
completely discard, then that justifies putting
it under the overflow.
The other option as well is obviously, 'cause
this pattern takes up the entire action bar
at the top, if you did have other options,
other actions, that you wanted to put under
the overflow button for example, you couldn't
really have room for both the large buttons
and the overflow.
So that's a case where you might wanna pick
the most likely candidate as a stand out one,
like maybe just the done button and then have
other options under the overflow.
>>Adam: Yeah, that's a good point.
And I guess, like, I don't know if this way
that users would, I guess you'd have to analyze
how users use this application, but if it
was unlikely to undo via common action to
discard what you find there, I'd say push
it into the overflow menu, have 'done' as
the primary action.
That also means that, say, if the user hits
the back button, they know that we're going
backwards and we're gonna save whatever state
was there rather than not knowing if it's
gonna be done or discard.
>>Nick: Actually, my take on this was that
this isn't the kind of application where you're
gonna install it.
You're gonna go in and set up a bunch of interval
times--these are the workouts which I'd like
to do.
>>Adam: Yep.
>>Nick: So you're gonna go in there and do
a bunch of them.
And you're probably just gonna set them up
and you're either gonna want to save it, say,
"Yeah, that's it."
Or, you're just gonna decide, "Oh, no.
That's not what I wanted."
Discard it.
Throw it away.
There's not actually gonna be a lot of curation.
You're not really gonna be coming in and out
and changing it very much.
So this is why I went to the plain done and
discard.
If you did think that people were gonna be
curating them, using them a lot more, then
you might go for the pattern with just the
'done' button and discard under the overflow.
>>Adam: Excellent.
Well, I think we're almost out of time.
[pause]
We don't have any more slides.
So, any other last thoughts, Nick, before
we call the show for this week?
>>Nick: Yes.
So, I wanted to use just a little bit of time
that we have left just to go over a few headlines
in the world of Android design.
Just pull out some activity that's been going
on in the community and really highlight it.
So, for me, last week we had an event here
in London called DevFest London, which is
run by local Google developer group, which
is awesome to meet up with a bunch of Android
developers as well as one of my favorite Android
designers, called Marie Schweiz, who was over
from Berlin, who draws lots of cute Androids
and was going around the Hackathon prettying
up everyone's applications.
So that was really awesome.
But out there in the design world, I also
wanted to call out an excellent blog post
I saw last week from Juhani of AndroidUIPatterns.com.
It's a fantastic blog.
He did a great job of putting together a bunch
of community tools which have been out there,
put out there for helping you to customize
the Holo controls as well as using the assets
you go to create a Holo-looking icon and the
action bar generating studio to customize
your action bars.
So, he did a really, really nice post pulling
those three brilliant tools together, showing
how you can use them in conjunction to customize
your app.
So check out AndroidUIPatterns.com for that
post.
>>Adam: Excellent.
And this is not really new news this week,
but something I just did wanna quickly mention
is the draw pattern, which is becoming very
popular recently.
For those of you who don't know, there actually
is a section up on the design site.
It's under the action bar page which has some
information on our best practices around implementing
a draw, how it should work.
If you are building draws out there, I would
encourage you to look at that and try and
follow those guidelines before everyone implements
this pattern and does it differently.
It would be good to standardize around that.
We don't have any code samples out at the
moment for the best practice pattern, but
at least the design site's been updated with
some information there.
>>Nick: Yeah, I'd say for the major takeaway
for the draw pattern is look at the YouTube
application, is the best way right now.
The best example we have is implementation.
>>Adam: Yep.
>>Nick: So, our advice is that the draw shouldn't
move the action bar, 'cause that's such an
important anchor in your application, that
you shouldn't be really shifting that in and
out of the way.
And the draw should come from underneath that.
And also the draw should only be available
from top-level navigation items.
So, once you go down in your view hierarchy,
you shouldn't have instant access to it or
else it just ends up as like a bag of links
rather than having any kind of structure to
it.
So those are my major takeaways and tips for
implementing your draw patterns.
>>Adam: Fantastic.
Alright.
Well, we're out of time.
Thanks for tuning in and we'll see you next
week.
See you guys.
>>Nick: Cheers.
Bye.
[synthesizer music]